all right some extraordinarily explosive
new allegations that have surfaced in
the last 24 hours regarding the former
guy that guy the orange Menace mango
Mussolini whatever right you know the
guy I'm talking about the first is that
failed former president Donald Trump
asked his lawyer to lie to the
government for him and this is just an
unbelievable story best leaven from
Vanity Fair reporting surprise Trump a
pathological liar reportedly asked his
lawyer to lie to the government about
his classified document cash the
ex-president wanted his lawyer to say
he'd returned everything in February
which was obviously not the case this
relates directly to the other Trump
lawyer Christina Bob who eventually did
make the claim that everything was
returned it was a lie and as I told you
on I believe Monday she has now lawyered
up Maga making attorneys get attorneys
best Levin writes in uh quoting The
Washington Post The Washington Post
reports that in early 22
the ex-president asked Alex Cannon an
attorney who'd work for both the Trump
organization and the Trump campaign
to tell the National Archives and
Records Administration that all
materials requested by the agency had
been turned over despite the fact that
Trump was still in possession of
thousands more government documents now
another thing we learned yesterday is
Trump personally packed a bunch of those
documents but we will get to that but
the point is Trump knew the documents
hadn't been returned because he had them
okay according to the post Canon who had
quote facilitated the January transfer
of 15 boxes of presidential records from
Mar-A-Lago to the National Archives
after archives officials agitated for
more than a year to get all original
presidential records did not feel
comfortable making such a claim in other
words it was a lie
he reportedly told people he didn't know
if all the requested material had been
returned and quote other Trump advisors
also encouraged Canon not to make such a
definitive statement did Canon hesitate
because he was aware of the fact Trump
had a long history of lying about
everything all the time who is to say
Canon didn't respond to the post's
request for a comment so think about how
absurd this story has gotten we still
don't really know the motive for why
Donald Trump kept these top secret and
other documents we don't know where the
ones that are still missing to this day
went that's another story there's a
dozen layers to this we have the picture
of the folders for top secret and
otherwise restricted documents which
were empty when the FBI found them
obviously Donald Trump didn't take empty
folders meaning the documents are
somewhere and we don't know where are
they at Bedminster another one of Donald
Trump's clubs golf clubs whatever you
want to call them we don't know we but
the point is not only do we not know the
whereabouts of some of those documents
we still don't really know the motive
for taking them because the stories
we've been told don't make any sense
Trump wanted it for his Library he never
talks about his Library he doesn't care
about his Library Trump wanted them to
read Trump doesn't read Trump wanted
them in order to write his Memoirs Trump
doesn't write there's no
plausible innocent reason
why he would want those and then you get
into the not so innocent reasons which
include selling them or whatever the
case may be the other aspect to this is
that remember the justice department
thought the situation was serious enough
to conduct a search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago now this isn't a criticism of
that decision this is just a reminder
that if the justice department felt this
was that serious
there may have been reason they believed
something was about to happen with these
documents if the impetus for the search
warrant was less about were imminently
charging Trump but more about we have
reason to believe he's about to do
something with these documents
then that would be a whole other area of
exploration but then there's Trump
wanted his lawyer to lie
Trump knew the documents hadn't been
returned
and he instructed his lawyer to lie his
lawyer didn't do it Alex Cannon
eventually Christina Bob another lawyer
was willing to make that claim on paper
and she has now obtained a lawyer and is
willing to cooperate with the Department
of Justice and she herself is facing
possible legal trouble and then the next
part of this is something else we
learned yesterday Trump personally
packed a stash of documents to take to
his house one of our sponsors is all
form the easiest way to design your own
custom sofa I have one from all form
unlike other companies all form lets you
choose the fabric the size the shape
color even the color of the legs I have
not one but two all form sofas I've had
them for years they look good as new
definitely the most comfortable
Furniture I own and it gets even cooler
because all form sofas are completely
modular you can buy a sofa and if you
move you can adapt it to the new space
by adding onto it or rearranging its
elements that is definitely not
something you get from your typical Sofa
Company all form has everything from
eight piece sectionals to love seats and
arm chairs everything is made in the USA
using premium materials all form makes
sure that assembly is really easy I
didn't even need any tools which is good
because I have very few tools and you
can keep the sofa for over three months
and send it back free if you don't like
it for a full refund right now all form
is giving my audience 20 off all orders
at allform.com Pacman the link is down
below